we're here at digital experience the
press preview of some of the cool CES
stuff and worth an icon booth with the
new d for this is nikon's new top-end
camera the DSLR obviously does still
photography also does video and video is
really where some of the greatest
innovation has come here I mean on the
still side there's a new 91,000 pixel
sensor that will recognize faces for
great autofocus stuff on the video side
you've got full 1080p in different crop
modes which effectively give you more
zooms with different lenses you've got
up to a 2.7 crop which if you're
shooting video was say a 600 lens you've
suddenly got about a fifteen sixteen
hundred lens for incredible zoom quality
still a full 1080p something that I
really love about this camera also is
the buttons are oriented for both the
horizontal and vertical shooting you've
got the exact same controls mirrored on
both front and back so no matter how are
you shooting the controls are right
where you're used to you've also got
program real joysticks if you want to
customize some of your controls it's a
six thousand dollar body and it'll be
available in February